I'm here training with George and Pierre
probably the greatest fighter of all
time and also one of the nicest guys of
all time
not today next we came on the wrong
thing my friend
all right
yeah
dies and dies
hey
advice well
it's actually pretty good standing
position I think
sometimes
you reach a little bit too much so if
you reach out to me
it's easy for me to take a good position
or reach out to me
I can probably like
trying back on you so what I would
suggest is don't worry I get closer with
your feet before you you
seek contact with me so don't go here
go closer to establish it yeah
yes
[Music]
foreign
in MMA
there's different Stars
I like to be using
proactive and reactive
very often I use one of my longest
weapon as a decoy to get in your leg use
my Jab
to create a distraction
then
I can get in
um
other guys for example
like Habib or more like
chain wrestler they shoot sometimes but
they're very good at using for example
the defense has
like
pushing you to defense and then from
there
they're using their
their resting from there so I'm more of
a
more of a dynamic up yeah I like to
explode so that's one of my strengths
which khabib is very good for example at
uh
very good technically and it's very
strong in isometric strength I I heard
so he's very good with this style of
wrestling
do you think you can take uh the bead
down I think I think I could yeah I
think he could take me down as well but
so how do I defend against this
so so there's there's many ways
um first you need to be aware of the
distance control that's one of the
things that was the best at
to master the distance control you need
to master the footboard to be always in
balance and ready to explode
a lot of guys I don't know how to manage
distance control also because they know
that good footwork they cross their leg
they go all over the place so when you
move it's important when if I go left I
push off with my right
how much left if I go right we should
put my left I go back I push with my
lead
I go forward I push with my back this is
the basic thereafter
you can use different illusion so if I'm
here I look and like I'm more of a
threat to you that if I'm here but I
mean I'm at the same distance
so one of my favorite which setup I take
down a single or double I use my jab
which is one of my longest weapon of
course my legs are longer but I like the
jab to create the distraction so if I'm
here you see me coming so I use a
distraction I'm here and like a cobra
like a snake will launch itself on its
brain I'm using my body to Boom so
you're you have a false spelling of
security now because you think I can
touch you but because of my leg
and my job start outside of your field
of vision so I'm not doing this
I'm doing purposely I'm putting it down
and I'm here and I'm attracting your
attention here because I'm moving my
hand
boom once I tag you once or twice
now I have a perfect setup because
you've not been fighting you have a
short-term memory
you you always remember what hurts you
the less and it's my job then I can very
I plant a seed in your mind and I can go
hop and get in easier you finish how you
drop there's many ways the best
highest per second move is the elbow
deep double leg so when I get him
I try to look across when I step across
so again then I go elbow deep the reason
why I don't only go with my legs is
because if I if you're stronger and
bigger than me and you sprawl from there
I can have a hard time but if I go elbow
deep
because of the leverage you can't Sprout
once I mean I look across and I drive
across
to put you down sometimes you'll fight a
guy
like for example best pain was very
strong and I couldn't drive across and
so when that happened
if you can't drive across you turn the
corner
guys it that's they open up on the other
side would you like to try sure yeah
here
yes what your
elbow deep here and now you're gonna dry
my Frost
yes step across with you yes
if you do it again
set it up John now go ahead go for it
hot
yes yes
exactly and if I give you resistance
once you get in I'm strong and I'm I'm
strong I'm spraying my leg you can throw
in the corner so yeah I've set it up a
few times yeah
I'm sprawling yes
very nice you feel you feel the
difference yeah so if if he's too strong
you go on the other side don't force
order don't waste your energy for
another
try to be as economic as you can as
possible you could be whatever on the
ground what's the difference in
suggestion for you and uh well there's a
lot of difference yeah
I believe in
Jiu Jitsu especially in the guard you
can't stay in mid-range yeah I don't
want to cover it I guess like if I'm in
the standing position
I want to cover like this my head is off
the ground my muscle in my abdomen all
are contracted so it's possible for you
to damage here but because I'm
contracted
it's less likely so I want to focus all
the protection on my head you're okay
with this yeah it's okay it's okay but I
want to be here so there's a gap where I
can see you here if I'm here it's not as
efficient because you can go on the side
and it's easy for you to grab grab my
wrist put it down and hit yeah if I'm
here it's harder for you to control my
arm if you want to grab it it's hard for
you to grab so that's the first thing
another thing if your handers are here
I want to take away your hand on me I
want to fool you fool you
to me I want to control your head and
your arm and from there there's many
options I like to take that clamp
because it controls your elevation and
you can't hit me it's either I'm very
close to you or
I'm very far are you trying to get up
I'm very far yeah if I can't get up no
problem I'm using my leg to push you
away or I can use the tip of my feet to
create distance so you need to be aware
that I can kick you in the head too so
it's either very close or very far over
on top on top yeah so if I'm On Top the
best position for me to be
ultimately is
not even Mount is to have it your back
left you to the floor
from this position because now you
cannot hit me I can't hit you and I can
either knock you out or submit you this
is the worst Mount is
the second best because I'm having a lot
of control Mount and also with my knees
under your armpit
the worst would be in your guard so it's
not as bad as if you would be in a jiu
jitsu competition because I have the
gravity on my side but if I'm here I
need to respect three rules I never want
to
you to put my hands on the floor your
submission all kinds of things you can
very easily wrap my arm and wrap my head
closer distance and now it's a thing
so nowhere another floor
I don't want you to have your head
higher than my head because if your head
is iron in my head you have a guillotine
it's very hard for me to control and do
anything for you if my head is is lower
than your head and another thing
the third thing is I don't want to let
you take an angle of me so if you take
an angle to do a GG Academy you see you
need to take an angle so if I take away
that angle
I kill your reference so my hands always
on you never on the floor are you
kidding are you trying to hit a little
yeah I gotta hit them at the same time
if you try to raise your head up
I don't accept that you might have the
high if you try to take an angle
I put them back in line
so if I respect these three rules as I'm
as I'm respecting this rule I can cause
damage even if I'm in the guard but my
goal is always eventually
to pass the guard get to a more dominant
position I love it it's a in a in a
nutshell that's that's what it is about
well thank you
to watch
it uh take steps on his martial arts
Journey we usually I think he's very
strong much stronger than the average
man
he's got a lot of a lot of heart he's
very tough so I've always found that
uh by by Far and Away the most important
thing two people get into a question the
skill level trumps everything else in
terms of what's going to turn the
outcome the skill Deeds sorry skill
Beats
that's not to say other things aren't
relevant but skill is more relevant from
what I understand is proposed opponent
is almost two years of training
experience that's a big Advantage so it
will be an uphill battle I will say
hello about it that he deeply impressed
of George myself with his overall
ability to ask for something very
quickly is extremely intelligent and
sees what is the Crux of the problem
identifies what would need to be done
um but I also believe that he's
probably one of the busiest human beings
on the planet that said these guys doing
martial arts training martial arts
because it's pretty Heavens yeah I think
ultimately the deepest distance
I think
there's two people who
have put themselves in a position where
they can create
greater benefits official management
than almost anyone else
and so there's a sense in which I wish
they would focus more on that than
fighting each other all right so one
more round this is for everything it's a
submission yes sir
for the greatest fighter of all time
hey
guys
they do next